[Música]
gracias por acompañarme en esta charla
soy lucía calderón
soy doctorada en ciencias políticas y
sociales quiero comentar un poco acerca
de mi vida soy la séptima de una familia
de compuesta por mi papá mi mamá
ocho mujeres y un varón
cuando era niña a mi hermano le quedaba
más remedio que jugar con nosotros
éramos su entorno más cercano y
obviamente jugábamos juegos de niños y
él nos enseñó cómo boxear cada vez que
nos ponía supuestamente a boxear contra
él nos decía pongan los brazos al frente
no los bajes tiras el golpe y lo vuelves
a colocar nunca bajes la guardia nunca
bajes los brazos
con los años esa enseñanza recibir a
través de estos juegos infantiles me
sirvió para enfrentar las vicisitudes de
la vida para entender cómo hay que
enfrentar la vida
cuando yo tenía ocho años
siempre tuve muy claro muy claro a
partir de esa edad que yo quería ser
universitaria yo quería ir a la
universidad yo quería terminar una
carrera universitaria
entonces mi empeño se enfocó en eso
toda toda mi trayectoria académica
escolar fue pensando en que alguna vez
me iba a inscribir a la universidad y
afortunadamente ocurrió
seguí todos mis estudios llegó a la
universidad y elijo un área que es la
comunicación que es un área apasionante
que yo he disfrutado muchísimo todos
estos años porque me formó como
periodista entonces cuando cuando llego
a la universidad
entiendo muchas cosas acerca de la vida
pero también acerca de la comunicación
humana
acerca de usar las palabras adecuadas
correctas para comunicarnos entonces
termino mi instrucción universitaria en
el 86
ya parece tiempo yo tenía un hijo
pequeño y tenía que trabajar duro para
sacarlo adelante
entonces me dedico a trabajar en el
periodismo en diversos medios de
comunicación
sigo adelante pero llega un momento en
que digo a ver qué sigue para ti
qué siguiente para ti en el plano
profesional en el plano de prepararse
académicamente y decido ingresar
a estudiar la maestría pero para poder
estudiar la maestría
también toma en cuenta que quería tener
un poco más de dificultad no en esta
tarea de atraer más conocimientos he
decidido irme a estudiar la maestría de
eeuu pero antes tuve que aprender inglés
cuando fui aceptada en una universidad
de eeuu en la universidad de carnet work
decido llevarme a mi hijo también
conmigo él iba a entrar a la
preparatoria entonces los dos nos vamos
en la estudiada su preparatoria pues yo
a estudiar mi carrera
y bien va avanzando la maestría también
tendría no nada más el tiempo en contra
porque durante todo todo el tiempo que
estuve trabajando pues ahorre para poder
pagar esta estancia en eeuu y obvio los
ahorros se acaban entonces yo tenía que
terminar lo más pronto la maestría y
entonces la termino en año y medio
comparado con con otros compañeros he
sido en esa universidad hasta ese tiempo
había sido la que tardó menos tiempo en
terminar una maestría año y medio
mientras que otro compañero lo había
terminado en un año
pero para poder llegar a estudiar la
maestría transcurrieron 14 años de mi
vida 14 años de trabajo constante de
años en que los horarios eran agotadores
en el periodismo esto es así sabes a qué
hora entras pero no sabes a qué hora
sales
todo ese esfuerzo pues obviamente
redundó en poder desarrollar la maestría
en el tiempo récord y también en
prepararme más solo que cuando termino
de su diabla
vuelvo a querer insertarse en el mercado
laboral y me encuentro con que me decían
bueno es que estás sobrecalificada
tienes una maestría en eeuu estamos
hablando del año 2001
sabes inglés entonces pues no te podemos
pagar y yo la verdad quiero decirles que
hubo una noche que no esté con un ataque
de pánico dije y ahora qué voy a hacer
yo voy a hacer porque mi hijo todavía le
faltaba un año de preparatoria en eeuu
yo tenía que financiarlo sus estudios y
entonces recibo una propuesta de trabajo
para para insertarse en un gobierno del
estado de un estado en el área de
comunicaciones que bueno pues va yo
siempre había estado reacia a
participar en actividades oficiales
porque como periodista uno mantiene una
línea una línea que quiere decir respeto
a la gente respeto a las ideas de los
demás respeto a lo que la gente opina
reflejar en los medios de comunicación
para los cuales yo trabajaba eso la
libertad de expresarse libremente de
hablar con la verdad y siempre el hecho
de ligarse un poco a un gobierno
pues como periodistas sientes que te
limitas te limitas mucho pero dije bueno
es que finalmente voy a tratar de sacar
lo mejor de esta experiencia voy a
aprender de comunicación institucional y
saben con el paso de los años me di
cuenta que fue una decisión correcta
aunque en ese momento no me lo pareció
entonces seguir trabajando duro y llega
el momento en que cambian de gobierno y
digo bueno ya está aquí terminó con
dentro de un área gubernamental yo me
retiro de esto vuelvo a periodismo
intentó regresar al periodismo y me
encuentro con que los salarios eran muy
bajos no alcanzaba ayuda a cubrir mis
necesidades
y surge una oportunidad de fundar y
dirigir una revista de ciencia en una
universidad estatal eso me encantó
yo estaba cercana a cuestiones
científicas pero pues no directamente y
allí en esta en esta oportunidad que
tuve a través de esta universidad pude
desarrollar ese es el gusanito que yo
siempre tuve por la investigación yo lo
hacía como investigación periodística
pero aquí ya era investigación
científica
saque adelante esa responsabilidad y con
el paso del tiempo me di cuenta que era
el momento de volver a las aulas y para
ello tenía que elegir a dónde ir y para
ello también tenía que dejar quemar
naves dejar en standby mi carrera
profesional y dedicarme de lleno durante
cuatro años a estudiar un doctorado
afortunadamente cuando llego a la unam
de donde soy egresada en el posgrado de
ciencias políticas y sociales
encuentro que aceptan mi proyecto de
investigación les gusta mi proyecto de
investigación que les platicó brevemente
un proyecto de investigación está
enfocado
a observar a estudiar a analizar a la
gente en el estado de tamaulipas
construyó un entramado comunicativo para
mantenerse fuera del peligro
esta es la experiencia de vida que tuve
al ingresar al doctorado también me pues
me fraguó en otras áreas no en poder
explicar mi tema de investigación ante
públicos diversos en congresos
internacionales en congresos nacionales
en los coloquios son cuatro años cuatro
años de vida en donde uno se olvida de
la el tema laboral y se dedica
completamente a estudiar completamente
incluso la familia reciente porque es
muy exigente un doctoral pero vale la
pena pues bien termino mi doctorado en
el 12 de agosto del 2016 y se me
presenta de nuevo el mismo escenario
vuelvo al mercado laboral vuelvo a
tratar de insertarse en el mercado
laboral y vuelven las mismas situaciones
de esta sobrecalificada no hay espacio
para ti
creo que tienes que dedicarte nada más a
la investigación porque no las clases
y digo pero porque nada más voy a
dedicarme a la investigación de las
gracias porque no también insertarme en
una área donde pueda aplicar mis
conocimientos también donde pueda
contribuir a desarrollar otro tipo de
trabajos bueno entonces como veo esta
resistencia
y qué hago es de estar habitando de
estar viviendo en la ciudad de méxico-
me regreso a tamaulipas ahí es donde
empiezo a
tratar de insertarme en el mercado
laboral no encuentro esa oportunidad
como ya se los expliqué entonces lo que
ocurre es que empiezo a hacer
investigación me invitan a hacer
investigación y yo colaboro en esas
investigaciones muy interesantes y
también yo promuevo investigación por mí
misma no luego se presentan una
oportunidad de regresarme a la ciudad de
mexico y tratar de encontrar un espacio
en mi área de comunicación para trabajar
y lo encuentro y lo encuentro y entonces
viene una experiencia agridulce por un
lado la maravilla de trabajar en mi área
de comunicación para lo que me he
preparado todos estos años por otros
situaciones que entorpecen la labor del
trabajo y se tuvo que dejar de manera
definitiva entonces
cuando se me invita a dar esta plática
empiezo a reflexionar sobre qué es lo
que está pasando para nosotros los que
hemos egresado de un doctorado y
encuentro datos muy interesantes por
ejemplo
el organismo que se dedica a estudiar
este tipo de temas uno de ellos es la
organización para la cooperación y el
desarrollo económico la ocde que
establece que en méxico de acuerdo al
inegi somos 126 millones 14 mil 24
personas de acordadas al ex censo del
2020 ok hasta ahí todavía pero cuando te
vas a los datos duros de la ocde dice
que en méxico sólo el 0.1 por ciento de
la población tiene un nivel de doctorado
y dice también que méxico ocupa
el último lugar entre los 37 miembros de
la ocde de los estados adheridos a este
organismo también dice
en el
2017 9000
300 600 personas egresaron del nivel
doctorado en méxico de las cuales más
del 50% son mujeres
también indica que en todo este en este
punto de la investigación
méxico se dedica sobre todo a los
doctorados en ciencias sociales mientras
que otros países dedican esfuerzos en el
área biológica o de matemáticas algo que
tal vez méxico tendría que estar
reconsiderando para poder enfocar mejor
los esfuerzos en esta área de
especialización de alta especialización
en méxico somos entonces de acuerdo a
los resultados del censo somos 126 mil
catorce personas que tenemos nivel de
doctoral
y yo me pregunto en un país con 126
millones de personas porque 126 mil
personas no podemos encontrar un trabajo
que además de que donde podamos aplicar
nuestros conocimientos
también tengamos las condiciones
laborales que nos permitan
desarrollarnos
y poder mantener una familia poder vivir
tranquilamente y podernos dedicar de
lleno para lo que nos preparamos tantos
años
entonces cuando cuando decido aceptar
limitación para la plática digo esto
tiene que tengo que ver también qué está
pasando con mis compañeros de doctorado
cómo les está yendo
a los que contacten que tenían más de un
año de no platicar con ellos
me explicaron a grandes rasgos que ellos
han vivido a una situación similar a la
mía
que se han encontrado con que llegan a
su centro de trabajo y las condiciones
en las que se elaboran son arcaicas
en las condiciones en que se elabora es
todo está establecido por personas que
tienen cierto grado de conocimientos
pero que no han avanzado en su
preparación
entonces provocar innovación en sus
empleos resulta difícil también se
encuentran con que están subempleados
con que no son valorados con que los
sueldos son muy bajos que no les alcanza
y que tienen que multiplicarse con
jornadas agotadoras donde combinan un
trabajo que les permite insertarse en el
mercado laboral y tienen que combinarlo
con dar clases lo que implica un
esfuerzo mayor
y luego también
menciona en este tema del género de
donde las mujeres aunque estamos
empleadas según la voz de el 87% de las
mujeres que hemos regresado de un
doctorado en méxico tenemos un empleo
comparado con los hombres y los hombres
tienen el 94 por ciento o sea ahí ya
llevamos una desventaja en el plano como
mujeres
pero cuando uno se acerca a la realidad
a verla directamente se da cuenta que si
tenemos empleo pero este este empleo no
es para que nos preparamos
estamos subempleados psuv aprovechados y
creo que es el momento de empezar a
pensar en cambiar esta historia dice
decía uno de mis compañeros a quienes
entrevisté me dice es que pareciera que
se está cumpliendo la profecía cuando
alguien me dijo
pues tú ya estás si estudias un
doctorado tu destino ineludible es dar
clases
porque esa es la idea que se tiene que
quien regresa de un doctorado
solo está capacitado para dar clases
y eso es completamente falso
el nivel de preparación que tenemos nos
permite desarrollarnos tanto en el campo
privado como en el público es más
podemos construir puentes de
entendimiento entre ambos campos pero
también es necesario que se entienda
algo que es fundamental
todos los compañeros a quienes tuve
oportunidad de encontrar de reencontrar
de que me compartieran generosamente sus
opiniones todos
consideran que
deberían de estar mejor aprovechados y
saben por qué
porque usted que me está viendo
usted que me está escuchando
que vive en méxico que paga impuestos
usted pagó nuestros estudios
por lo tanto nosotros tenemos una deuda
con usted
como ciudadanos como ex ex estudiantes
de doctorado como egresados de doctoral
tenemos una deuda con la sociedad
mexicana y por lo tanto necesitamos que
nos escuchen que nos presten atención
que haya políticas públicas más
completas que den seguimiento a todas
estas personas que egresamos de un
doctorado en el país tanto en
instituciones privadas como públicas que
queremos quedarnos en nuestro país que
no nos interesa irnos a vivir a otro
país porque nuestra educación la
financió la financiaron los mexicanos y
las mexicanas entonces es importante que
no perdamos esto de vista porque de otra
forma vamos a
desaprovechar toda esa fuerza todos esos
conocimientos que esos cerebros tienen
para poder construir un país mejor
entonces yo sí pediría que si alguna
alguien nos está escuchando que prestará
atención a este punto y también que los
mexicanos pidamos que se nos den mayores
oportunidades porque podemos servir más
podremos ayudar más
y sabe por qué
porque yo estoy contenta de que pese a
esta historia que yo les estoy narrando
de vicisitudes y de de subir la cuesta
estoy segura que hay muchos jóvenes allá
afuera que quieren estudiar un doctorado
y que no quieren estudiar en méjico o
que se quieren ir al extranjero pero
quieren volver a méxico entonces a ellos
hay que prepararles el camino hay que
fertilizar lo para que cuando ellos
lleguen encuentran oportunidades y sus
conocimientos nos sirvan a todos los
mexicanos y estoy muy contenta porque a
la vez que me encontré a mis compañeros
de doctorado a mis ex compañeros
a todos les pregunte
una vez que dejaste que tomaste una
decisión de vida que quemaste naves que
decidiste un trabajo que tenías en ese
momento que tal vez te daban muy buen
nivel de vida y dijiste yo me voy a ir a
estudiar un doctorado y te encontraste
con una realidad que que supera en
desafíos a lo que tú esperabas te
arrepientes de haber estudiado un
doctorado y todos todos contestamos que
no que lo volveríamos a hacer por todo
lo que significa para nosotros como
seres humanos pero también quiero
decirles que durante este breve scouting
que yo hice con mis compañeros no
encontré una sola historia de éxito que
no ha batallado para encontrar trabajo
una sola historia pero una golondrina no
hace verano
y esa persona es la excepción que marca
la regla donde dejemos de ser la
excepción yo quisiera que seamos la
regla en este país que se hagan
programas específicos para atender a
todos los egresados y que podamos
encontrar dónde desarrollar nuestras
capacidades
de verdad que lo espero y saben algo y
saben porque lo espero
porque yo he bajado los brazos porque
así me lo enseñó mi hermano porque así
lo he hecho todos los días y porque voy
a seguir haciéndolo yo les agradezco
muchísimo que hayan sintonizado este
vídeo